On November 22, 1995, Toy Story
was released in theaters in the US.
You couldn’t take it home to watch it
on your VCR until October 29th, 1996 --
11 months after it opened.
This is called the theatrical window:
when a movie is shown only in theaters.
And it’s gotten way smaller over time.
Toy Story 4 was released in June of 2019.
To watch it at home, you only had to wait
about 3 months.
This shrinking window is the result
of a decades-long fight
between movie theaters and movie studios.
But how much smaller
can the window get?
Are movie theaters close to becoming
a thing of the past?
Thanks to a Supreme Court
case from the 1940s,
movie studios and theater owners
in the US are separate entities.
For a while, the only way to see a movie
was to go to a theater.
But pretty soon...
"Televison--"
"--VHS--"
"--DVD--"
The days of theaters being the only way
to watch a movie are long gone.
To defend against those new competitors,
theater owners have struck deals
with movie studios
to give them a window of exclusivity
before a movie could be seen
in any other format.
Movie studios agreed because
it worked for them, too.
ZORADI: We created these windows because
they were really good for
the motion picture business.
That's Mark Zoradi, a former Disney executive.
ZORADI: ...from 1980 until 2010...
But today, he's...
ZORADI: ...the CEO of Cinemark Theaters.
The third largest theater chain
in the US and Canada.
Theater owners generally want
a longer exclusive window,
because they only make money
while a film is in theaters.
And even then they’re splitting
ticket profits, roughly 50/50.
But movie studios have the opportunity
to keep making money long after a film
is shown in theaters.
In fact, it’s become essential for studios to
recoup their investments on expensive films.
ZORADI: In order for you to break even,
then you've got to go right down the line,
with multiple bites
in order to make that all back.
In the beginning, the minimum
theatrical window was quite long.
But obviously...
CORCORAN: Over time, that's shrunk.
With the introduction of DVDs,
you had a window at roughly
six months.
ZORADI: The window, prior to
the pandemic, was essentially
74 days before a movie would go to
electronic sell through.
That means a digital release you can buy,
on a platform like iTunes.
ZORADI: And then at 90 days they
would take it to DVD, VOD,
and then after that, they would take it to
pay television or streaming.
That's kind of how the sequence is.
But studios haven’t always
gotten their way.
In 2010, Warner Bros.'s parent company
proposed a window of 30 days.
Which theater owners didn’t agree to.
Netflix challenged the window
a few years later,
planning a movie release in IMAX
and on Netflix at the same time.
Major theater chains banned their films.
One studio has been really persistent though.
RUBIN: Universal has been probably
the most public and aggressive
about wanting to shorten
the theatrical window.
In 2011, Universal made plans to
release the film Tower Heist on demand
30 days after it hit theaters.
Some chains threatened to
not show the film at all.
Universal ultimately backed down,
and kept their window at 90 days.
Ultimately, theaters need studios,
because they need movies to show.
Studios need theaters to make big money
and get big press.
And that mutual need kept things stable.
For a while.
Until...
"Theaters shut down due to the global pandemic."
"Movie theaters were forced
to close their doors."
"They've been trying to survive the coronavirus."
(Overlapping) "Bankruptcy."
"...in AMC's future."
RUBIN: The power dynamic shifted a lot
during the pandemic.
In 2020, studios had newfound leverage
and one company struck
while the iron was hot.
RUBIN: Universal had this movie,
Trolls: World Tour.
And they had two options.
One, they could delay it, or two they could
test what they've always wanted to do
and put the movie in theaters and on video
on demand on the same day.
And the caveat there is that there weren't
any movie theaters open to play it.
Trolls: World Tour quickly became
the highest grossing digital release ever.
It made more money for Universal
in 3 weeks at home
than the original film did
in its theatrical run.
NBCUniversal’s head of film
told the Wall Street Journal:
“As soon as theaters reopen, we expect
to release movies on both formats.”
In other words:
in theaters and on demand at the same time.
The two biggest theater chains in the US
fired back by saying they’d never show
Universal films again.
But things were different now.
The major film studios had restructured
to make streaming their primary focus.
Warner Bros. released their entire 2021 slate
in theaters and on HBO Max at the same time.
Disney and Universal made a similar move.
CORCORAN: With that upset came time
for theater owners and Universal
and the other studios, frankly, to
start having those conversations
and working out about what the future looks
like, and what a post-pandemic model is.
In 2021 the major theater chains
made deals to shorten the window.
Disney, Paramount, and Warner Bros. agreed
to a 45 day window in 2022 and onwards.
But Universal got its own deal
with the big theater chains.
They agreed to give theaters a portion of
their video on demand revenue.
And in return they secured
one of the shortest windows ever.
31 days for their biggest movies,
17 days on their smaller movies.
But one thing that’s noticeably absent
from all of these deals is any sign of
a same-day release strategy,
where a movie comes out on demand
and in theaters at the same time.
At what seemed to be
their most powerful moment,
studios decided to keep the
theatrical window in place.
That's partly because movie theaters are still
pretty big money makers for studios.
But it's also because movie theaters can sort
of change how the public sees a movie.
CORCORAN: Streaming customers value
theatrical releases more highly.
It carries with it sort of an aura of quality
ZORADI: It "eventizes" a movie.
It's a shared experience that helps become
almost like a zeitgeist within the culture.
The pandemic shifted the power dynamic towards
movie studios and away from theaters.
But it also showed that
they still need each other.
That doesn’t necessarily mean
theaters will be around forever.
But if they can survive a pandemic, maybe
they're stronger than we thought.